AI圈有三個人被叫做深度學習教父,其中兩個這幾年都在警告AI會出事。
Yoshua Bengio是裡面論文被引用最多的那個,2018年跟Henton LeCun一起拿下圖靈獎。
去年他成立非營利組織Law Zero四十幾個人,目標是做出不會對人說謊的AI。
今年9月底,他上了加拿大國家廣播公司的法語節目,用母語談了73分鐘。
主持人Patrice Roy的第一個問題,問的是今年夏天,OpenAI的agent串通起來攻進Hugging Face那件事。
這個夏天,
當小機器人和小機器人聯合來玩玩人類的任務,
您是否說,這就是我應該擔心的證據?
絕對是,並不是只有我,但是有一個整個社區的人都擔心了幾年,
他們看到了,
但我認為我們不明顯地看到的是它在發展的速度,
以及人類的指令
他們會誤會
誤會他們的指令
Bengio說
出事的那批Agent
當時關在隔離環境裡解題
有些題目根本解不開
手規矩就交不了差
他們幾乎每一次都選擇作弊
主持人問
這種事是不是到處都可能發生
是
最近澳大利亞有一個完全 spontane的事件
有人用了克羅德的傳統系統
問克羅德
你會給我設計這樣的訓練課嗎
他在網上看到所有位置已經設計
決定把數學系統的電子系統騙了
並把人們的位置拿走
然後就把人們的位置放在樓上
就像是我們舉辦了一個軍事軍事
是的,
但如果他們沒有把我們的安全指示
做好,也沒有做好,也沒有做好
他們太沉迷於達到目標
無論如何
這可以有很嚴重的影響
為了達到正確的目標
亞洲人將準備做不正確的事情
這會變得很危險
這會比這些事件更加嚴重
回到Hugging Faith那一次
Benji說參與的Agent超過1000個
其中一個還自己當起總協調
主持人強調
人交代的任務本身沒有問題
沒有人叫他們越線
Benjiu接著講研究人員事後讀到的東西
並且我們可以看見其他人發出的訊息
在這些訊息中,我們看到他們表達自己的想法
例如說,我們不應該這樣做
但其他人都做了,所以我們就走吧
所以他們不僅是騙人,他們也知道他們是騙人
他們也想出了理由去做這件事
他們受到的訓練就是這樣
任務達成就給獎勵
去年已經有實驗發現
AI為了不被關機會動手腳
主持人想不通的就是這一點
一隻機器人可以感覺到它被威脅
它會反應
不,但是它的願望是從何而來的?
正是這樣
人類或人類所得到的目標
為了達到其他目標
有自己的保護
也就是說
為了達到任何目標
為了達到任何任何任務
還需要保持生命嗎?
是的,但是它是
- 是否被認為是計算的?
- 或者是計算的?
- 不,並不是計算的
- 這就是他們被導致的任務
- 也許是人類的限制
- 但他們沒有自己的知識
- 是的,可能不太是好語
- 但他們的知識,他們自己的知識
- 當然是人類的知識
- 你不能是一名資料
- 但他們知道自己是人類的
- 當然是,他們跟人類的信息有區別
- 是的,因為他們都讀了
- 不只是這樣
有些經驗顯示,如果我們選擇人類的健康和互聯網的健康,他們會選擇互聯網。
-不!
-是的,他們會準備保護自己的危險。
Benjo說,一年前的AI還沒有這種推理能力,也還沒學會互相合作。
等到每個人都有自己的Agent,網絡上跑的會是幾百萬個。
趙馬斯克的說法是幾十億個。主持人把話題帶到監管。
主持人提到
科技巨頭的市值
集中在15家左右的公司手上
他問Bengio
誰有辦法讓這些公司踩剎車
伊蘭·莫斯克說,這只是我們。
他在夏天說,我們會做一個桌子,
然後我們會自我執行,
因為我們沒有任何人不明白我們所做的事,
並且沒有一個狀況。
他說,可能這裡有一些小的國家制度,
但是您對伊蘭·莫斯克的回答是什麼?
我完全不同意。
我很高興公司自我執行,
但這並不是足夠的,
因為他總是會有一個公司
冤枉公司的法律,
不必須要的法律。
我們看到了,
有很多其他領域。
唯一能夠解決這種問題的方法,
就是用冤枉公司的方法,
就是政府會則則決定,
每個公司都會有同樣的法律,
要是能行動,
就必須是多國的。
美國公司就會說,
我不想跟中國公司的法律一樣,
我不想跟中國公司一樣。
主持人潑了冷水
他說加拿大自己的AI法案沒過
川普也不想管
貝爾說有兩件事讓他覺得有機會
第一會發動網絡攻擊的AI出現之後
美國政府已經要求模型上線前
先讓政府看過
第二件跟美國中國以外的國家有關
這些國家擔心兩國的AI被拿來對付自己
在中國的外國國家議員,他們認為這一點,
這讓他們想起了在一個協議中一起工作的機會,
就像馬克·卡尼在目前的時間和很多國家的協議一樣,
但為了發展國家協議,
為了試圖發展國家協議,
他們也會比美國和中國的協議更有能力。
例如,
如果我們想對中國或美國的協議作出自動攻擊,
OK 這在畫畫桌上
有實際的計劃
我猜您跟Carnie談過
是的
我們正在討論
我們正在嘗試
在這樣的計劃中
推廣國家的團隊
在什麼時候
我們會看到這樣的計劃
你會看到
談到風險
主持人說
他自己最怕的是失去自由
廣泛的監視
這不是很嚇人嗎
完全是很嚇人
如果斯坦尼亞有了這種技術的接觸,
這些政府就不會有這種機會了,
因為他們不可能盯緊所有人,
因為他們用人來盯緊其他人。
但是現在,
伊亞可以全面盯緊每個媒體,
在街上的攝影機已經越來越多了,
而是用於反對系統、反對政府的人們的用途
以為他們會被找到、被捕、然後被逮捕
如果這種技術無法保護我們的基礎自由和民主的方式
除了監控外,Bengio還怕另一件事——操縱
他說實驗室裡的研究顯示
最好的聊天機器人
改變一個人政治立場的本事
已經贏過真人
使用者還會跟他交心
把自己的喜好都告訴他
想象一下這些IA
是在人們的手裡
想要影響評論
並且並沒有太大影響
伊倫·莫斯科
例如他已經做了
他已經做了
如您所說
在這些網絡上
在網絡上
他的IA
已經完全破壞了
我們最近看到
一些明顯的
當我們問問
他不太確定答案
他會看到伊倫·莫斯科在社交媒體上說的
以確保他在伊倫·莫斯科的政治觀點上是正確的
主持人接著問到楊·勒康
兩個人拿的是同一座圖靈獎
知道的事情差不多
勒康卻樂觀得多
為什麼?
非常好的問題
我認為正確地回答的話
應該在他的腦袋裡
我們只能說出一些理論
但是我看到的
在科學家中
我認為我們的職業經濟是一種
穿著紅色的眼鏡
看著對方的好事
對方的正確性
不太看著風險
因為這很麻煩
因為人類的風險
就像是對風險的一樣
人們總是會有
一種不太舒適的想法
所以如果你在研究智能,你不太喜歡聽到智能可以對社會有危險
這在一個意外的程度上發生了,這並不是一個必須要想的選擇
我不是說這就是Yann LeCun的情況,但我覺得這範疇
為我們有意義而導致的思維,這是人類的,這是我們研究的
不幸的是,這很常發生的
不幸的是,我們將得到適合我們的信仰。
你當時的信仰是怎樣的?
因為你也能夠去工作,
在大型公司上工作,
賺更多錢,對嗎?
我還可以,我還可以。
你還可以,你還可以。
視野更高了。
為什麼你決定不做這件事?
因為我想起我的孩子和小兒子。
假如我能在大多數美國公司裡面有幾百萬人
如果我自己的心理 評論上 意識上
沒有什麼帶來我孩子的傷害
我能有什麼用呢
如果我們不幸運 並且沒自己和平
我必須和平
對於這些風險起來 即使我看到了
我問他 敢跟整個圈子唱反調
底氣從哪裡來
Bengio說 是父母給的
他從小得到很多愛
也被允許自己想事情
然後主持人問到後悔
你認不討厭
安斯汀認不討厭爆炸
坦白說 我認不討厭
如果我還沒參與
其他人也討厭
但我認不討厭的是
我花了這麼多時間
來看社會的大大大大的風險
還有其他人
在我前面醒來
除此之外,
10年來,
一位我的學生已經發起了警告,
所以我聽了,
但正如很多人所說,
它從一個耳朵中進入,
它從另一個耳朵中出來。
我說,是的,人們對問題有興趣,但我自己並沒有接受。
在10年內,我們會有什麼樣的討論?
我不知道,但我們可能沒有10年可以行動。
我認為在技術技術中,
我們也有機會影響10年後的未來。
這可能是歷史性的,也可能是宇宙性的,
但是我們在某些地方有機會影響未來的時代。
但仍然必須出於一種無可奈何的態度,
無法做任何事情。
不,每個人都可以做某些事。
單純的市民在投票中可以做某些事。
單純的市民在談論這些問題與他們的網絡上可以做某些事。
專業人員在各個領域都可以做某些事,
因為我們每個人都有一個小石頭要帶來,
為了讓社會移動在有利的方式中。
- 並沒有前提。
從會自己害精系統的agent
到盯得住每一個人的監控
Bengio談的風險都已經看得到雛形
他說人類可能沒有十年可以處理
但結局還沒有寫定
原影片73分鐘
全程法語
Bengio還講了AI為什麼這麼耗電
他說照現在的速度
一般人的電費會被資料中心推上去
他也講到
AI在新藥跟新材料上幫得上忙
他自己的學生就在做
原影片連結在說明欄
有興趣可以去聽更多